Video compression works in slightly different ways.
Each video is a sequence of images and
each image can be compressed with spacial redundancy,
exploiting aspects that humans tend not to notice.
Also there is temporal redundancy. Between any
two video images, or frames, there might be
very little difference. So if this person was
walking towards a tree, you might see a
version of the image that's almost the same,
except with the person shifted slightly to the
right. Video compression uses a combination of static
image compression on what are called reference frames,
or anchor frames, sometimes called I frames, and
derived frames, sometimes called P frames. The P
frame can be represented as the I frame, compressed. If we take the I frame and
divide it into blocks, we can then see that the P frame is almost the same
except for a few blocks here that can be represented
in terms of the original I frame blocks, plus a few motion vectors.
A common video compression format that's used on the internet is called MPEG.